as requested by a few of you
i'm going to put together a scenario in
which john wick and sam fisher
are put up against each other in order
to theorize who i believe would come out
on top
this is a little different to some of
the previous versus videos because not
only are they from different universes
but they also come from different media
types which further adds a different
layer of complexity when comparing their
skill sets
that aside if we took the legendary
hitman from the john wick movie
franchise
and put him up against the protagonist
from the tom clancy's splinter cell
series of video games
novels and comic books who would win
[Music]
an orphan that was born in belarus
russia he grew up in an orphanage called
ruska roma under the care of the
director who brought him to america
the orphanage is one of many criminal
organizations which falls under the rule
of the high table
a council of high-level crime lords
consisting of 12 seats
they are responsible for governing the
underworld's most powerful criminal
organizations
it is considered to be the ultimate
authority of the underworld and is
feared and respected by all
each seat at the table belongs to a
member of a well-known criminal family
which includes the russian mafia yakuza
and triads to name a few
during jardini's time at the ruska roma
and under the director's strict tutelage
he developed many skills including
various martial arts techniques
eventually he decided to change his name
to john wick
wick eventually became a professional
assassin and joined the continental a
hotel that caters entirely to criminals
there his reputation grew and he earned
the nickname the boogeyman
he is both respected and feared within
the criminal underworld
and the main reason for his reputation
is simply the fact that he is so lethal
and never unarmed the only way to kill
an assassin
is either have them wounded or unarmed
and wic
is always armed his perseverance to hunt
down those who have wronged him
make him an extremely lethal and
dangerous foe and someone who should not
be crossed
his enemies have simply begun to realize
that you can take john wick away from
the weapons
but you'll never take the weapons away
from john wick
described as a stoic and very serious
individual wick really speaks more than
absolutely necessary
he is a man of actions not words and as
well earned his reputation as the
boogeyman
he is deadly highly confident in his
abilities greatly respected
and feared by many criminal
organizations and other assassins
and the fact is he has never failed a
mission
although a strong moral code is nearly
non-existent in his line of work
wicca holds one and because of this
mindset never willingly threatens
innocent people or drags him into his
assignments
despite his unique and deadly skills
wick prefers to avoid altercations if
you can
oftentimes he is able to convince his
enemies to back down without any
conflict
and will let them go unharmed
however if betrayed or wronged his usual
calm and collected nature
becomes near non-existent and once
angered he will stop at nothing until he
eliminates his target
no matter who or what stands in his way
born in 1957 in towson maryland
fish's father was a 25-year veteran case
officer for the central intelligence
agency
and he worked undercover in moscow
during the cold war
very little is actually known about his
childhood especially before the death of
his parents however with very little
else left for him he was enrolled in a
military boarding school
when he was older he was accepted into
the united states naval academy where he
eventually graduated in 1980 with a
bachelor's degree in political science
and was then commissioned as an officer
in the u.s navy
not long after his file was flagged for
recruitment by the navy seals
of which he joined after passing the
grueling selection process and training
program
during the mid-1980s fischer worked for
the cia
under the cover of being deployed as a
diplomatic aid in eastern europe
operating in afghanistan east germany
and the soviet satellite states
in the years leading up to the collapse
of the ussr
eventually fisher moved back to the us
and took a desk job with the cia
where he worked in weapons development
as well as studying experimental
weaponry and information warfare
during his time as a navy seal fisher
participated in a number of special
operations in bolivia
senegal colombia kosovo and the persian
gulf
he also led a number of operations
around the world in various conflict
zones
amid his naval career fisher also spent
nearly three years working as an
intelligence analyst
and over time he was awarded the defense
distinguished service medal
and around 1996 was honorably discharged
from the navy
a recently retired sam fisher underwent
training at the farm at camp perry
virginia
this training was to demonstrate to the
director of the third echelon that he
had the appropriate skills to
successfully perform in the field as a
member of the newly created splinter
cell program
the third echelon a top secret
organization was tasked with leading the
american information warfare initiative
the primary goal of this organization
was to serve as the equivalent of the
special forces
in the modern age of technology and
information warfare by physically
obtaining intelligence in locations
where all other means had been exhausted
its most significant initiative was a
splinter cell program in which lone
operatives called splinter cells
did field work in sensitive areas around
the world
like a sliver of glass these units
operated seamlessly
undetected by electronic and human
enemies alike and were able to
infiltrate highly sensitive
locations and collect intelligence by
any means necessary
sam fisher's employment history features
a lineup of top tier special force roles
including navy seal operator and
instructor
cia operations officer third echelon
field agent
nsa officer fourth echelon field
commander
and i won't even get into the work he
does with team rainbow
this opened him up to a vast amount of
training and qualifications
like advanced weapons training seal
qualifications training
scuba training craft mega center access
relock training
and much more not a lot is discussed on
john wick's earlier years in regards to
training
however certain details about a style of
fighting give an indication that wick is
clearly skilled in the art of conflict
and has received extraordinary training
and gun skills and marksmanship
this is obviously very advanced and high
grade and not something he would have
just picked up from the streets or even
a local trainer
he has a tattoo across his back reading
fortis fortuna ajuvet
which means fortune favors the bold this
implies that he was once in the united
states marine corps
2nd battalion 3rd marines given his
extensive knowledge of security
surveillance
and the ability to strategically plan
it's likely that he was in the special
operations
unfortunately none of this is confirmed
so we can only speculate
but for the purpose of this video we're
going to assume this to be true
this is a tricky one they obviously both
have considerable strengths here
one is essentially a super special
forces operative and the other a
legendary assassin of assassins
but we're just talking about their
weapon handling skills in this section
so let's just remove any sort of
equipment advantages that either side
may have
when it comes to accuracy and precision
both seem to be a very high level
and based on the available information
at a similar level
to use gaming terms they both use aimbot
with wix aimbot being tuned ever so
slightly higher when it comes to pistols
but when it comes to accuracy regardless
of range these two are absolute beasts
of the trade
however what begins to separate them is
their movement while firing
will do his best to evade gunfire
regardless of what type of gear he's
wearing
he prefers not to be seen and has really
been shot
in the novel he states that his training
has taught him how to effectively move
throughout the environment
fast and use everything around him to
his advantage
to be much harder to hit where wick will
move through a gunfight
seemingly undeterred by the fact that
others are shooting at him
yes more often than not it's because he
doesn't need to waste the energy on such
movement
because he'll hit them first anyway but
this isn't always true
wick has been shot before many times
most of the time he'd just shake this
off and continue on his way if they
weren't immediately fatal
this was particularly obvious in the
second and third movie where he required
medical attention soon after
but this isn't a question of wick's
endurance or ability to take damage by
any means
in fact we'll be covering that a bit
later more that wick seems to be more
likely to be hit in a gunfight through
his movement
especially against a foe just as
accurate as himself
i can hear the comments now there is no
way that fisher could be as much of a
crack shot as john wick
no way but conviction and blacklist and
probably others to be honest
just show how fast and precise fischer
can be
time and time again he can be seen
performing complex maneuvers
outdrawing and headshotting several
enemies in what seems like less than a
second
john wick is an incredibly skilled
martial artist and hand hand fighter
he can be seen using a number of
different styles including brazilian jiu
jitsu
judo [ __ ] aikido and krav maga
has shown his ability to quickly
outmaneuver and outmatch most opponents
rick also shows the ability to adapt
based on the fighting style of his
opponent
through studying their movement during
the fight
through his training potentially with us
marines which shows considerable skill
with the use of knives and other melee
weapons
but while showing skill in this area
close quarters combat certainly isn't
his strongest field
when coming up against physically
stronger foes or opponents with more
experience
it can take in time to adapt often
having to rely on the environment to
gain the upper hand
and while this itself is a talent the
aspect of using one's environment to
gain the upper hand
is where sam fisher excels
much like wick fisher is skilled in
multiple martial arts
he's well versed in the arts of warfare
and close combat particularly hand to
hand
his martial art of choice is crab maga
which is an unarmed style based around
the making of split second decisions and
the use of reflexive responses
to threatening situations but he also
utilizes several other combat
disciplines
on top of this he is highly proficient
with knives and other edged weapons
as well as carrying up to three or four
different variations fisher gained fast
experience and combat knife training
with the navy seals
and also the karambit of which he
learned to fight while training abroad
sam fisher is a seasoned combat veteran
of exceptional skills
particularly in close quarters combat
this particular area
is his bread and butter
outside of firearms handling and close
combat john wick is extremely skilled in
a number of other areas
for example tactical planning work is
proficient in casing out
planning and executing assassinations
this also helps him with being spatially
aware in combat situations
and able to make proper use of the
environment wick is also an expert
driver
able to effortlessly evade enemies and
even able to use the vehicles to engage
in combat
another skill he utilizes often is
stealth but this really isn't his forte
he's more for hiding in plain sight but
he'll sometimes pull it out if he has to
however this is what i truly believe
separates the two
as well as a vast number of skills that
he has acquired over the 20 plus years
of service
fisher is all about stealth
stealth is fish's main way of
approaching just about any situation
if he isn't within stealth he will do
his best to get back into it
which he does rather easily and often
there is a reason why people call him a
ghost
if wick loses sight of fischer even for
just a second
he's gone his entire job relies on
stealth and non-detection
he is highly adept at blending into the
shadows and moving silently
fischer's had to sneak into some of the
most heavily guarded facilities in the
world
including the white house the third
echelon hq and the cia headquarters just
name a few
even if wick was standing face to face
with fischer he would be bouncing in and
out of cover so quickly
that the best weapon accuracy in the
world wouldn't be able to help him
fischer can vanish flank his enemies and
leave them shooting at the spot they
thought he was
right up until the point he eliminates
them
i didn't want to go into too much detail
in this section as explaining some of
the individual pieces of this gear alone
could take up a whole video
however i do think it's important to
mention as it does differentiate the two
characters somewhat
sam fischer is issued with the following
gear upper echelon tactical operation
suit the offset or operational satellite
uplink
the in-ear subdermal implants
multivision goggles
and much much more summing up all of
this gear only complements
fish's high level of ability when it
comes to stealth from his bullet
resistant suit that uses a micro
roughened exterior that partially
diffuses light
to his low light multiple environment
night vision goggles
his gear and technology give him a clear
and almost unfair advantage
fischer is so stealthy that it's
actually canon that he doesn't generate
footprints
even on malleable surfaces like snow or
sand
wick has absolutely no way of detecting
him unless fischer allows it
when it comes to wix gear apart from an
absolute crap ton of different firearms
and weapons
his bulletproof suit and pencils i guess
he doesn't really have a lot else that
would impact the outcome of this fight
given what happens to wick in the movies
and the sheer amount of damage he can
take
it didn't seem fair not to include
something about the durability of each
of these characters
wick is a man who maintains a strict
level of training his strength
durability speed agility stamina and
reflexes are in top condition
while his strength may not be as high up
the list as some of his other attributes
he is still very strong able to easily
overpower and restrain larger opponents
knock me out with a single strike and
break bones with relative ease
wick's durability however is insane
even after taking multiple gunshots stab
wounds and blunt force trauma
not only did he survive but he was able
to carry on with little effect on his
abilities
he's even fallen from tall buildings
with only the concrete floor to break
his fall
and survived the only thing greater than
his durability
would be his pain tolerance wick is
frequently injured
but is able to shrug off physical blows
cuts and bullet wounds with ease
when cutting off his own ring finger and
having the wound cauterized
he barely seemed to flinch but it isn't
like sam has remained untouched
he too has shown great feats of near
superhuman strength and durability
there has been examples where he has
broken his way out of a block of ice
and shattered toilets and vanities with
a single strike
he too has jumped from buildings several
stories up and walked away from it
unscathed
i couldn't count the number of close
proximity explosions he has survived
and at least two separate helicopter
crashes and if anyone is familiar with
ubisoft's storylines
this is quite a feat as they love to
kill off characters with helicopters
fischer has been captured and
interrogated violently beaten
strangled and literally shocked for days
on end
yet he remained conscious and of course
refused to divulge any information
at the end of this ordeal after he was
rescued doctors said that it would take
weeks for him to recover
or even be able to walk but instead
fischer climbs to his feet
and immediately gets back to work there
has even been one situation in blacklist
where he was exposed to a nerve agent
but he managed to resist the effects for
a considerable amount of time
while he finished off the job of killing
a bunch of bad guys before passing out
shortly after while these two characters
are obviously complete badasses
the conclusion of who would win is
pretty clear-cut to me
john wick is a complete crack shot with
any weapon he gets his hands on
and in close combat he can more than
hold his own but sam
fisher has all of this and more his
training
background experience the state of the
art tech he utilizes
but probably most importantly his
techniques and tactics
particularly in regards to his use of
stealth wick would be taken down before
he was even aware of fish's location
even if he was allowed to see him first
i know there's going to be a bunch of
comments from people who are die-hard
fans of the john wick series
saying that it would be a much closer
fight but all i have to go on is the
movies
books games and any other fact-checked
information i can find online
and everything points towards sam fisher
absolutely dominating john wick
in every way a splinter cell agent
is the equivalent of an entire black ops
squad on their own
their main purpose is to infiltrate
impenetrable locations
and make it out of even the most
impossible scenarios
they're trained to perform the
impossible they're experts in the art of
stealth
and have peak human physicality and the
skill to make most men on the
battlefield look like uncoordinated
children
even without the high-tech gear fischer
has proven to be the elite among the
elite
in conviction he went up against
splinter cells that he had trained
himself
and while they had all the gear he was
still able to take them out with ease
where john wick tends to spend more of
his time walking in completely oblivious
to the idea of taking cover
getting shot stabbed and beaten to hell
by almost every group of thugs and
gangsters that he comes across
yes he is god-like precision but even if
fischer wasn't quite to the same level
his movement on the battlefield more
than makes up for this
he is constantly keeping tabs of his
environment and the people around him
making backup plans in the middle of
executing one and is always aware of
everything around him so that he stays
one step ahead
sam fischer is more well known to the
bulk of you watching this due to his
time as a video game character
and the only weaknesses he's shown over
the years has purely been done for game
balancing purposes
even his age isn't slowing him down yet
in case you couldn't tell i was a little
surprised by the number of requests for
this versus video
as someone who has watched the movies
and played most of the games the answer
seemed fairly obvious to me
but i enjoyed making this especially
since i had a good reason to watch the
movies again
so thank you for the suggestion i have
plenty more to catch up on but keep
firing away i should get to them
eventually otherwise thank you very much
for watching and i'll catch in the next
one
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers
[Music]
thank you